[Music]
what does genius mean to me I think
there are many brilliant people in the
world many people who are very very
intelligent so I think it has to do with
a line of dialogue that I think we have
in the first episode which is a genius
is not just answering questions but
asking questions that nobody else
thought as you don't need to raise your
hand to speak here there's a particular
thing that happens to you when you watch
people do something that they're really
really good at it's a sensation it's
like a it can be a six-year-old kid
drawing something that it can be a
painter like applying ball color but
they're just very very good
you kind of know whenever you witness
somebody being really excellent at
something it's a profound experience to
be able to be around it you know and I
think that to me really is watching
somebody doing something special unless
we can define time most people agree
that whoever the geniuses are and you
could save it's the people that can
combine ideas that are staring everyone
else in the face but they somehow
connect something that no one's even
thought about like Mozart's metronome I
found the quote that Schopenhauer lately
has this great quote where he says
talent hits a target that no one else
can hit genius hits a target that no one
else can see close your eyes and then if
you apply that to someone like Einstein
he would engage in what he called
thought experiments he'd just let his
mind wander and drift off and speculated
on what you know he was always obsessed
right from his youth what if I could
travel as fast as the speed of light
what would light look like next to me
now I'm imagining all his traveling
indeed the most elegant answer to the
question of what is a genius was given
to me by Ron Howard scientists we live
in the light of knowledge they're
working in their refining their
knowledge and they're testing things all
the time
some scientists operate at the edge of
the light where the dark is which nobody
knows was in the dark
but a tiny number of scientists jump
right into the dark and create their own
light around them it's a combination of
vision and absolute determination that
you're right that you're totally
convinced that this leap into the dark
that you've made is right and Einstein
definitely qualifies and that to me is
genius I have another question
[Music]